now they got grant williams on giannis
and then they back off jaylen brown's
got him giannis into his chest puts it
up and in 40 points for the great great
foul shot puck at 10.
clear out here and holliday takes a
three was challenged by williams
matthews gets it back holiday yacht is
one second left giannis missed the shot
no foul is called
here's connorton now giannis goes right
at grant williams steps
and gets the layout giving milwaukee
that was a great step great step through
to create the layout brown with the blow
by hands and miss rebound holiday
here's holliday against tatum with three
to shoot
tatum
now remember if you do that you have to
hit the rim and he does hit the rim
smart got it puts it up no tim won't go
williams another try harford no he tips
it in but it's afterwards the game is
over
[Applause]
it looked like the tip by horford was
after the buzzer sounded that would have
tied the game but it appeared that that
was after the buzzer meaning milwaukee
wins game three they're gonna go to the
monitor to make sure now the strategy
was excellent and you could see
that the coaching staff had relayed to
the foul shooter that you've got to hit
the rim and he did he hit the rim and it
and it became a scrum down inside now
just think of how many opportunities
that it went to get that rebound just
out look how many people are in their
convergence still on his hand huby this
game's over
the ball is still in the shooter's hand
at triple zero the game is over no
basket
milwaukee wins game three
103 101 and takes a 2-1 series lead